[Musik]
was glaubt net bekommt beim ein video
jetzt runter im gesäß er sich einen
krassen wandel an oder ja was geht neues
video ich hoffe euch jetzt gut auf jeden
fall haus heute eigentlich nichts selber
überlegt weil das kam alles von euch und
zwar hat mir eine liebe zuschauerinnen
link geschickt da geht so irgendwie um
sachen zehn dinge von den mädchen oder
frauen gerne hätten das ding dass jungs
also zehn dinge von den frauen gerne
hätten dass jungs oder wenn sie wüssten
dass hat um ehrlich zu sein wer mein
interesse geweckt weil ich bin ja ein
junge oder mann wie man es jetzt nehme
ich bin ja schon erwachsenen ja und ich
hab da mal reingeschaut und um ehrlich
zu sein weiß manchmal ein bisschen
überrascht deswegen gibt es das video
ich habe euch dazu noch aufs apple
gefragt als wenn ihr mehr slettvoll
kindes gerne zu etwas nütze den instinkt
für die werbung darf ich euch mädels
auch noch gefragt hey wie seht ihr dann
eure meinungen wovon denkt ihr wir jungs
oder männer wissen irgendwas nicht was
ihr gerne aber möchte dass ihr das
wissen
komplizierter wird auf jeden fall unter
dem titel ich würde mich als junges
mädchen video kommt 12.000 leicht oder
sagen was 13.000 und die website sieht
übrigens sieht herzlich aus nicht drin
als erst mal sieben punkte von dieser
schönen website und dann auf drei von
euch ja fange mit funk nummer 1 an und
warf ihr jungs oder männer müssen nicht
jeden tag oder mehrmals täglich uns
anrufen
sorry aber ganz ehrlich ihr frauen oder
mädchen müsst nicht jeden tag uns
mehrmals anrufen oder schreiben wenn ich
diesen satz von lese dann denke ich mir
welcher falls baku hat das was ich meine
wenn man ist eine freundin hat ist doch
schön wenn man die mal anruft natürlich
jeden tag fünfmal um zu fragen wo man
ist aber ich glaube das machen nur die
wenigsten und wenn jetzt nein das ist
nicht gut da hast du recht lieber autor
der nächste punkt ganz und vor allem
prahlerei kommt bei uns gar nicht gut an
ja ich glaube dieses video wird echt ein
bisschen new york ich kann natürlich
verstehen es gibt da natürlich die
frauen und es gibt diese frauen und es
gibt bestimmt ich trete immer von frauen
jetzt immer noch mädchen es gebiete
frauen es gibt diese mädchen also und
aus meinen erfahrungen wirklich das sind
nur meine erfahrung kann sein dass
andere ganz andere erfahrung gemacht
haben aber es gibt natürlich sehr sehr
viele die gar nicht auch zu augen müssen
jetzt mein alter ich konnte einfach gar
nicht weiter sprechen weil irgendwie ja
ich sag mal so die die was ernstes
suchen stehen nicht auf arrogant was
kommt jetzt hier ins nichts aber es gibt
auf jeden fall auch eine menge diese
voll auf die prahlerei und so abfahren
jetzt nicht von mir ich bin keinesfalls
arrogant oder sonstwas oder prag oder so
aber ich habe den einen oder anderen
kollegen den ein oder anderen freund den
ich denke so geht
und irgendwie funktioniert warum auch
immer aber das was hier steht stimmt
definitiv nicht zu 100 prozent sagen wir
zu 60 der nächste punkt kleine lügen
sind ok in maßen für mich heißt das
jetzt folgendes wenn man eine freundin
hat die luft auch um zumach sitze was
das ding ist ihr mädchen oder frauen
liegt ab und zu mal die jungs die da
kann ich auf jeden fall von ganz hinter
stehen vor allem wenn es darum geht so
bin ich echt die hübscheste bist du okay
stopp des waren schlechtes beispiel weil
an sich sollte das ja schon so sein aber
er wisse natürlich weiß meine also die
eine andere kleine lüge ist denkmal auch
okay der nächste probiert etwas
erotisches vorspiel muss sein wie
einfach das bei fag den film immer aus
die der typ sich aus legt sich sofort
auf seine partnerin drauf dass ich okay
dass dinge zeit wirklich jeder mit 12
oder eigentlich auch schon mit acht
keine ahnung zungen auch irgendwelche
speziellen internetseiten und sich
zugang zu speziellen inhalten
verschaffen kann dass man vielleicht
dann einfach so dass sich die
vorstellung von dem ersten mal so sagt
man einfach so komplett verändert ich
kann mir auf jeden fall richtigen
vorstellen beispiel irgendwo ein kleiner
junge 13 14 jahre alt guckt ab und zu
mal porto und hat dann sein erstes mal
und denkt so war ich muss genauso sein
der typ da in dem film das zum video
worauf habe ich eigentlich auf jeden
fall ja soviel dazu okay noch in form
von ihrer website der wunsch nach etwas
freiraum heißt nicht dass hier sollt
euch nicht melden da hat nun kein
rechtsstaat fehler gemacht der wunsch
nach etwa 2 raum heißt nicht dass ihr
euch nicht melden sollte ja gut aber
wenn mir zum beispiel gesagt werden
würde
ich brauchte mehr freiraum dann würde
ich das schon zu deuten mich erstmal
nicht zu melden oder ihr könnt ihr
natürlich auch zu jedem punkt eure
meinung vor allem wenn jetzt mädchen
oder frau weit in die kommentare
schreiben mädchen wieder fleißig durch
ok um ehrlich zu sein ich habe jetzt
erst mal genug von dieser zeit habe ich
auf jeden fall schon bessere artikel
lesen nicht vielleicht einfach mal mehr
auf euch und schau mal rein was eben
noch so gemerkt habt okay die jenny
schreibt es wäre cool wenn jungs mal
verstehen was für ein aufwand es ist
sich vor einem date fertig zu machen ja
ein kleiner aufwand ist da einmal durch
die haare dann zu einer machen und
irgendwas aus dem kleiderschrank oder
nicht gleich weiß dass du meinst mehr
ist sein ich würde gerne wissen wie
lange so im durchschnitt ein mädchen
braucht um mich fertig zu machen vor dem
ersten date für das erste date
zweieinhalb stunden oder so bestimmt
oder ok der nächste punkt okay dass wir
zick-zack nicht unbedingt greifen
sondern vielmehr auf natürlichkeit
stehen ist bei mir und meinen
freundinnen so war das ist echt harte
aussage wenn das jetzt kann ja sein dass
nur bei dir so schon dazu schaffe es
auch beim eingang freunden so das hätte
ich auch nicht gedacht also jetzt schon
gelacht so fast jedes mädchen steht
darauf
eine ewigkeit kann er sein bei uns nie
zustande schreibt ist auch mal einfach
einzelne die kommentare steht auf six
packs oder nicht okay war beschreibt
dass männer nicht immer dumme frauen
wollen wenn eine frau meissner ist als
der mann oder in irgend etwas besser ist
sind sie gleich den ersten verstehen die
welt nicht mehr
dazu wird mir jetzt einen spruch
einfallen mit dem man das ganze kurz
abrunden könnte ich würde schon sagen
wenn man jetzt halt in beziehungspartner
ist es schon wichtig dass beide ungefähr
auf
intelligenz level sind aber es gibt ja
auch diesen berühmten dumm klingt gut
und das war das nächste video von jungs
mädchen link system check ins am
donnerstag wieder
ich wünsche euch noch einen angenehmen
tag und wir sehen uns vertreiben